hi everyone my name is davidita rambam
and I will be presenting my study on the
topic relapse in AML post allogenic
hematopoietic cell transplantation and
intensive chemotherapy a transcriptomic
study
so I have completed my bachelor's and
masters from Amity University Noida and
I've also worked as a research fellow at
fine biotech
this project was carried out under the
guidance of Dr raghavendran l
so in order to understand the study we
need to understand what AML is so AML is
an aggressive form of blood cancer that
takes up one percent of all cancer types
leukemia as we know is blood cancer
acute means rapid so acute myelody
leukemias and rapidly Progressive blood
cancer that affects the myeloid cells so
what are myeloid cells
during the hematopoietic stem cell
lineage the multiple 10 HIPAA
hematopoietic stem cell differentiates
into lymphoid stem cells and minor stem
cells the lymphoids themselves
differentiates further into NK cells DNB
lymphocytes the myelid stem cells
differentiates into rbc's platelet
myeloblasts and muscles in the bone
marrow
so when this myeloid cells
count goes beyond 20 percent
or more in the bone marrow
or if it goes beyond five percent in the
blood AML can be diagnosed in most cases
now then let's take a look at what the
problem is and what the purpose of the
study is
so recent studies for the treatment of
AML shows that alloyed City relapse had
a high for your survival rate in
comparison to chemotherapy loan or a
combination of these two
so we'd like to dive into what makes the
difference in the survival at the
pathway and the genes associated with it
we would also like to study the
regulatory link between AML and
neurological autoimmune disorders
uh
we have obtained the data set from
Prodigy your database of ncbi
under the number
gse197417 and the expression profiling
was true height throughput sequencing
from the original paper they observe an
epigenetic marker prc2 to be the cause
of post-transplantational relapse
and a certain pathway antigen processing
and presentation alteration was deemed
as one of the main drivers of yellow HCT
transplantation relapse as well
coming to the study pipeline we first
collected the raw data from the Geo
ncbi database here we have collected
Rory towns of five diagnosis versus five
relapsed chemotherapy samples and five
diagnosis versus five relapse
transplantation samples
now then we
proceed with the dimensionality
reduction analysis using PCA after
quantum normalization
the PCA were plotted between pre and
post the Intensive chemotherapy and pre
and post transplantation
after studying the variance between
these two
we went ahead with a differential gene
expression analysis using d seg2
pipeline from the D by info server and
again and then proceeded with the
enrichment and pathway analysis using
gsea go and human gauge
to study the pathways and the enriched
or significantly regulated
Pathways and genes that are implicated
in this
treatment conditions
that led to the relapsed
now coming to the results section we
will first look at the PC analysis
here for the chemotherapy diagnosis
versus relapse we can see four of the
diagnosis samples in this part of the
quadrant
and three of the relapse samples in this
part of the quadrant
in the case of a diagnosis versus
relapse transplantation studies we can
take three of the relapse over here
and four of the diagnosis samples over
here
uh but there's not a clear separation
indicated in both these samples and so
we cannot say for certain because both
the diagnosis and the relapse are the
disease are in the disease condition
itself
if we take a look at the differential
gene expression study for chemotherapy
we can only see 5S rnas being
upregulated
here the red represents significant of
Regulation
these rnas on further analysis show
regulatory role in RNA biogenesis in
eukaryotes and this might be because of
the increasing demand of cell
proliferation of leukemia stem cells and
hence uh hindering chemotherapy
in the case of differential gene
expression analysis of
post-transplantation we can see a large
number of differentially expressed genes
that add to Adaptive immune response
cancer cell signaling Pathways
regulating leukocyte activation and
migration
T cell cytokine and effector cell
production all in all are aiding to
leukocyte cell proliferation and
migration
enhanced immune Escape
here we can see the post chemotherapy
and post-transplantation and which
pathways from the cake Geo pathway
analysis
in the case of chemo post relapsed
analysis we can see the pathways are up
regulated and mostly for which AIDS in
migration so it might have added a
myeloblast to migrate from the bone
marrow into the first Gene in the case
of transplantation we can see migration
as well and also some neural neuronal
morphogenesis
and there also seems to be down
regulation of pathways
such as MHC Class 2 protein complex MHC
protein complex and MHC complex binding
peptide antigen binding all in all which
AIDS in the
which is enabling to differentiate
between
uh differentiate between the
cell versus non-self conditions
here in the cake GSA pathway enrichment
analysis in the case of
post-transplantation relapse we can see
an elevated level in the cancer cell
progression Pathways which are Hydro
signaling Pathways CMP signaling pathway
djf beta signaling pathway cytosuchine
cytokine receptor interactions
which regulate or facilitate the
interaction
and the progression of cancer cells
and AMO cell migration
in the case of post chemotherapy we can
see that ribosome and ribosome
biogenesis and eukaryotic Pathways have
been activated
and which was also observed in the
differential gene expression analysis
taking a look at the pathway signatures
that are implicated in transplantation
we have neurological related Pathways
being down regulated tumor Progressive
Pathways being upregulated and tumor
suppressive Pathways being upregulated
as well these are the common Pathways
that
uh are implicated in this study
further analyzing the pathways using
human gauge analysis in case of
transplantation we can see there is a
down regulation in both the MIT one
pathway and down regulation in mhc2
Pathways where the green color indicates
down regulation and the red color
indicates of Regulation
so we can see both of them are down
regulated and these are important for
distinguishing
the cell cells from non-self cell cells
in this case there is also they also
affect the CD cells and CD cd8 and CD4
cells from recognizing
these cell for non-self and hence
hinders
the healing of target cells producing
cytokines and activating other immune
cells all in all adding to immune escape
and subsequently relapsed this pathway
was also mentioned in the original paper
another significantly regulated pathway
is the cell adhesion molecule pathway
here we can see two sections of the
pathway one is immune system another one
is the neural system in the case of
immune system we saw as in the last
slide that mat1 and 2 are both
unregulated whose main end product leads
to differentiating cell from non-self
cells and these domination might have
been the cause of
no allograft rejection taking place this
might have helped
then there's also the help percentage
cytotoxic cell of Regulation leukocyte
transothelial migration genes were also
regulated and these help in the transfer
of these myeloid cells from the bone
marrow into the bloodstream
these are all
linked to cell mediated adaptive immune
response in the case of neural system we
can see down regulated genes
when some of these genes have the role
in infiltrating the central nervous
system which may be the reason of
neurological disorder being implicated
hence
showing a connecting link of AML to
neurological disorder
now to sum up our analysis in
acute myelody leukemia was diagnosed and
remissioned by transplantation and
remission by intensive chemotherapy
occurred
now after that relapsed after the
transplantation occurred and relapse
after the chemotherapy also occurred so
in case of a transplantation there were
regulated tumor Progressive and
suppressive Pathways and along with
these neurological disorder Pathways and
genes related were also down regulated
from this we can conclude that in the
case of transplantation in the initial
diagnosis Day there might have been
susceptible to neurological disorder
because of immunocompromisation
and hence they were down regulated later
after relapsed
in case of chemotherapy a differential
gene expression analysis shows no
significant disregulation in Pathways
except for a particular of regulation in
the ribosomal
RNA synthesis
these however were interestingly
downregulated in transplantation
relapsed now we can use this mRNA
biogenesis Pathway to as a therapeutic
Target against this
chemotherapy resistance we might say
these are the references
thank you